hello welcome to the new rockstars my
name is Sam basher the Batman is storing
back into cinemas on June 25th 2021 and
this ain't your daddy's bat flick no sir
or ma'am we've got a spry young buck
donning the cowl and beating the snot
out of Gotham's best dressed criminals
Robby Bobby Robert Pattinson will be
joining director Matt Reeves for a new
chapter of the bet whether this is
acknowledging Ben Affleck or the DCU
it's too early to call as of right now
since the last we heard the film will be
following a younger Batman in his
formative years we've also got casting
news of multiple baddies and goodies
showing up alongside Edward :
but I've got a theory I've been piecing
together that I'd love to share with you
if you'll let me now this is based off
of existing kind book storylines along
with casting rumors and spoilers for
other Batman properties here's what we
know so far Robert Pattinson from
Twilight Fame and also please go watch
good time in the lighthouse he's in
those and he's incredible he will be
suiting up in the latex bat suit no word
yet on how nippled it will be but we'd
always dreamed Jeffrey Wright who most
of you probably recognized from West
world.we joining us as our new
Commissioner Gordon I'll say I'm a
little bummed that we're not seeing JK
Simmons return with that glorious
mustache but Jeffrey Wright is some good
casting no word yet on Batman supporting
staff aka Robin or Robbins or Alfred no
word of Jeremy Irons will be returning
but he's doing such a good job right now
is Ozymandias quote on Watchmen so I'll
take the wins when I can get them
speaking of win zoe kravitz is once
again being cast as Catwoman
excuse me Selina Kyle
fan-freaking-tastic choice if you guys
don't remember she played Catwoman in
the Batman lego movie and that one was
amazing
our last confirmation is Paul Dino as
the Riddler aka Edward Nash Jen that
name comes to be a little bit of a
surprise don't you think I'm only
familiar with the name Edward nygma
apparently in the comics Edwards birth
name is Nash tin and once he goes full
questionmark he changes his name let's
go ahead and keep that in mind for later
from a theory Matt Reeves are back
director helm the ladder to Planet of
the Apes prequels and did a phenomenal
job in my opinion and direct the
American adaptation of Let The Right One
In
Let Me In and if you want to see his
work with a bat themed protagonist
taking out people in the night there you
go so we've worked on the vampire movie
and now he's got one of the most famous
vampire actors on board to play it back
themed hero just putting all the pieces
together to make a wonderful look back
to the villains we've heard rumors at a
cornucopia bat villains will be
appearing in this film it sounds like
this will be a fully functioning Gotham
that fans will be familiar with but
they've ever read a comic or ever played
an art Gumm video game
as for who will be seeing we've heard
rumors for the past few months that
Jonah Hill might be joining as either
the Riddler anymore or the pagan now we
know that Jonah has stepped down for a
number of reasons that you can read
online so we're not going to be seeing
him but who will be our next penguin
I'll leave that up to you guys but
joining these two cuties we've heard
rumors that two-face Bane Scarecrow Mad
Hatter and everyone's favorite say it
with me if you know it Firefly could be
appearing in this film he's just a dude
with a wing suit and a flamethrower
but of course no confirmation as of yet
but I can understand the inclusion of
these characters most of these heavy
hitters we've seen divvy up Gotham into
different gang territories in the comics
or in the animated series yet penguins
iceberg lounge if you're familiar with
that you have Riddler's questionable
hideout pretty good if I see one Riddler
trophy of this movie I'm walking out no
I'll go find mine and I'll come back and
watch the rest of the movie and I don't
know Bane's hanging out in a Planet
Fitness or something each of these
characters while most have had their own
solo films versus the bat wouldn't have
to be the key villain for this film
except for one that I think deserves one
more swing at getting his more serious
bat flick that flick not that flack like
we said no official synopsis released
except for this will be more of a
detective story than previous films now
that we haven't had mysteries to solve
before in other movies but now I think
we're gonna be diving into a serious
crime thriller getting David Fincher
vines that immediately brings to ideas
that could be easily married together on
the big screen looking at the two most
iconic Batman tales in DC history I
think we've got the framework for a
solid bat movie turn your eyes twits the
long Halloween and hush let's start with
the long Halloween an unforgettable bat
tale following the holiday killer keep
the story tight I'll just say we see
Bruce Wayne teaming up with Harvey Dent
pre two-face and Jim Gordon to uncover
the systematic killings of members of
Gotham's crime families the maroney's in
the Falcone ease long story short we see
in this story a retelling of Harvey
Dent's descent into becoming two-face
and follows a gripping tale with many
twists and even uncovering the Thomas
Wayne had ties to the Gotham crime
family it really messes up Bruce's day
when he finds that out Bruce has not
only betrayed by his family but also by
his friend Harvey Dent now we've seen
this before in The Dark Knight in some
way so that's why I want to mention
hush now hush is unbelievably famous but
if you haven't heard of it before
hush pho is a conspiracy that involves
Batman's entire rogues gallery we're
talking every
buddy he even fights Superman in this
story incredible and this all leads to
the creation of one of his most iconic
villains in my opinion hush aka Tommy
Elliot we learned that Tommy and Bruce
were childhood friends and Tommy's
Harvard a grudge against Bruce since
then when Riddler approaches Tommy with
the knowledge that Bruce is Batman they
team up together to take Batman down
once and for all
now hush is one of my favorite newer
Batman villains and I could see him in
this film however since the reveal that
Paul Dana was cast as Edward Nash 10 and
not Edward nygma could we see the
Riddler taking over the role of Harvey
Dent or Tommy Elliot and start out as a
friend of Bruce assisting him along the
way and then turning against his friend
and becoming the Riddler that we know
and love we're talking full spandex
question marks up down Kane and a little
bowler cap we could see someone who's
been obsessed with being the smartest
person in the room his entire life
having to be the one to one-up his
longtime friend and rival Bruce Wayne
now if that specific origin for the
Riddler might not be your cup of tea
I'm a big fan of it we could still see
the Riddler team-up with the likes of
hush and two-face and manipulate them
due to their own falling outs with Bruce
my point is is that I think the most
impressive thing we could see in this
movie is a hyper-intelligent villain
that takes on Batman and I think the
Riddler is the man for the job
sitting up elaborate traps along the way
they would send Gotham's finest villains
after the bat along the way we could see
Catwoman teaming up with Batman to cover
the truth behind the plot to undermine
brews and take over Gotham you guys have
heard this before and there'll be plenty
of smooching along the way I guarantee
it now I know filmmakers have done a
solid job taking inspiration for comic
book storylines or events and making
them their own work for their version of
the character but I feel like this would
be the most reliable road map for the
Batman movie but what do you guys think
could you see the Riddler taking center
stage in 2021
versus Ravi Bobby Pattinson would you
want to see hush in this movie or have
him have his own solo film let me know
what you think down below and follow me
on twitter at Sam bash sure check out my
new show one more time with Sam bachelor
on my youtube channel or any where you
get your podcast it's a show where I
watch bad movies with my friends just
one more time see if they get good I'm
watching Suicide Squad I'm scared
subscribe the new rock stars for more
content just like this I'll see you guys
next time
[Music]